That is the Angel of the North - Antony Gormley's incredible sculpture
that stands as one of the icons of modern Britain.
But angels aren't all like that - at least not in Christian philosophy.
Pseudo-Dionysius the Areopagite - and I'm probably mispronouncing that,
and no, that wasn't the name he went by then -
was a Christian writer in the fifth and sixth centuries
and he, along with Thomas Aquinas, settled on the modern Christian hierarchy of angels.
And my word - if you wanted terrifying creatures you need look no further than angels
because yes, the ones in the lower orders, they look vaguely humanoid, as the term would be now:
but up at the top you have the cherubim.
And they're not cherubs in the sense of angelic little children with serene expressions, no.
They have four heads - a man, a lion, an eagle and an ox.
And then you have the thrones - they don't look like that gorgeous thing
they look like a wheel within a wheel, covered in eyes.
Seriously, if you wanted terrifying creatures from science fiction, it turns out that you can just go and look at some angels.
This angel on the other hand is a lot prettier,
a lot nicer,
and frankly,
even though I'm not religious,
this is a greater testament to God's work than any wheel, within a wheel with eyes on it.
From the Angel of the North, that is something you might not have known.
One more thing before I go - thank you very much to everyone who replied to my call for help a couple of days ago
I got an order of magnitude more answers than I thought I would
You're all amazing, thank you so much and I'm sorry if I didn't get to your comment - I did the best I could.
Oh and one more thing - if you want a bonus fact
There's as much of that angel below the ground as there is above.
20 meters or so down to the bedrock.
Otherwise? Well, the wind might just make it fly away.
[Subtitles by Paul Pollard.
Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]